good morning everyone
so welcome welcome to this lovely
conference welcome to PI data Berlin
2015 so just a couple of quick words
from the organizers here to get y'all
started so welcome everyone so the first
thing I'd like to say is it's all about
the community so this conference is
wouldn't really be possible without all
of you in this crowd I'm really happy
you at all alterna turned up so I think
we have in fact sold out entirely soar
there are 0 tickets left well done on
that regarding the wireless so there is
wireless there's information about the
wireless sort of spread throughout the
room then the toilets are on the first
and the third floor and the schedule is
online so we decided not to print any
schedules because it's online and we
didn't really want to waste that much
paper also you can tweet using the
hashtag PI data Berlin there's also an
account here PI data Berlin on twitter
and you can follow that for updates so
if there's going to be any updates
during the day i'll try to post them to
that account so this room is called the
inno space and it's the right hand side
of the schedule so if you have a look at
the schedule all of the talks on the
right hand side here are going to be in
this room and then there's another room
across the hall which is called the
event space and that's going to be for
the tutorials then there's going to be a
social event with the with the BB q
tonight so that's going to be outside
I've been told the weather is going to
be really nice so that's that's going to
be downstairs and in front of beta house
also please avoid touching the video
equipment so there's two cameras in this
room and one camera next door and
they're sort of there a little bit
fragile so try to avoid sort of touching
them or connecting your laptop's to the
to the sockets near them and if they
like if the cameras turn off for
whatever reason it means that the
streams will break down which brings me
to the next point so there are streams
so i think i am actually stream
this right now yeah I don't maybe not so
the streams are here yeah this is the
stream so i can see myself talking here
with a little bit of lag um yeah jolly
good so what else so the this isn't
streaming media dot ccc eee so there's
basically two streams available we're
hoping that they're going to be stable
throughout the day but you know as these
things go they might break down let's
hope they stay up so the the two last
points are there's going to be lightning
talks this evening before the social
event there's a flip chart at the other
side of the room near the registration
desk if you want to give a lightning
talk this evening please do write it
down on the flip chart it's on a
first-come first-served basis so the
quicker you sign up the more likely you
are to be able to hold look your
lightning talk are there any questions
ok no questions then it's my pleasure to
introduce Matt Matthew rockland he's an
open source developer he works for
continuum speaking of continuum we'd
like to thank our sponsors so all of our
sponsors are listed over here continuum
analytics blue yonder the python
software fab and a foul I quant Python
Academy the unbelievable machine company
and plot Lee and of course the CCC video
operating center for doing these amazing
videos and recordings and bringing all
the equipment and staying here till one
o'clock in the morning to get everything
set up yesterday so thank you very much
to all those people
so Matthew is an is an open-source
developer and he works on on some really
amazing Python tools amongst those are
simple so he's contributed to sin pi
he's also recently done some work on it
on a tool called task which is sort of
focuses on parallelism and and arrays
and that's what he's going to be talking
about today so give it up from that I
Matt Franco huh when should I finish
part so um i think you have 50 minutes
let me just check the schedule my time's
running out so go ahead yeah till 10 20
so 50 minutes great so hi everyone my
name is Matthew Rockland I work for
continuum of those who don't know
continuum is a for-profit company sort
of embedded in the open source PI data
ecosystem so they make anaconda is
because most you'll know about them the
consulting they also apply for
government grants so all the work that
I'm gonna talk about today is sort of
open source grant funded work so
Canadian sort of just generally tries to
make the pie tajikistan better
incentives are sort of in the right
place for that so I usually talk about
vas Kor A's task is a project that sort
of grew out of blaze this other big
project but I'm sorting think the
schedule says blaze today's we talk
about to ask because it's the first
talked the most going to talk sort of
more generally not just about my library
but about parallelism in general in PI
data sort of the state of that why it's
a little bit wonky and maybe why it's
going to be better in the future so
there's sort of standard library talk
and then coupled with you no more
general or diurnal talk so again they're
sort of my talk it's about desk array
which is a multi-core use all of your
records out of core is uses data sets
the larger than your memory numpy clone
so it looks and feels like numpy but is
maybe bigger and then surrounding that
we'll talk about parallelism sort of the
core of desk and how it can be used
maybe to do more parallelism and then
the gill sort of why we care about that
that's where we talk about today it's a
long talk so questions at various times
really welcome so you have a question
please flag me down and say something
okay so when we talk about parallelism
I'm going to sort of classify data sets
into three sizes one is a sort of the
gigabyte size or less this fits in
memory you'd only need one core it runs
in 40 seconds most data fits here this
is what works in your laptop there's
sort of the terabyte sighs this you can
conceivably use on a laptop this sort of
fits in your hard drive but it's sort of
inconvenient and I would say that if
maybe ninety five percent of datasets
fit in a gigabyte ninety-nine percent of
the data sets fit in a terabyte I have
found the sort of big heavy workstation
to be the sort of ideal computing
environment in that case but you'd also
go to spark clusters or not other than
sort of the petabyte scale and if your
google or handle all of the tweets for
the world every day in sort of the
petabyte scale I'm mostly going to focus
today on problems that are in this sort
of terabyte range if you're in the
gigabyte range and I suspect that almost
everybody is in that range you could
ignore everything I'm going to say if
you're in the petabyte range I have
nothing to give to you you need to use
Hadoop or HBC or spark or whatever so
I'm sort of just talking about the star
but range was sort of a very interesting
space a lot of sort of fun data sets are
dis sort of entering that space okay so
we have this sort of PI data conference
it's built off of this software stack my
job a continuum is sort of think about
that software stack and ways to make it
faster or easier to use and so it's
really think about the whole software
system as a unit rather than a
particular library and this whole
ecosystem is really defined off of by
the libraries that build off of numpy
and pandas this n dimensional array in
this sort of in-memory table and so
here's my sort of image of that
ecosystem so the very bottom we have
languages like C and Fortran and Python
right and ignore the colors for now
we'll get back to that in a bit and it's
the unfortunate we have library is like
blossom la pack they sort of very hard
core libraries that are written for
speed and artists amazing
and all of that we have numpy top of
that we build lots of library code sigh
pie or the psychedelic psy kit you know
things like an image scikit-learn
there's you know visualization there's
pandas etc and again I'm sort of on top
of all of these libraries we've built
many other libraries and the interesting
thing that comes out is that all of
these libraries can now talk to each
other because they all use the same core
data structures okay so it's really
fascinating that we can store data in
hdf5 or pie tables or be calls or
whatever load it into memory and then do
stats models or ass I could learn
psychedelic and then visualize it with
matplotlib or bouquet or Seaborn and we
can change out any of those and not have
to have any coordination between those
libraries so the developers as libraries
talk to each other a little bit but not
too much then they'll have to agree out
of time this all agreed just to use
numpy rays and that agreement sort of
allows you to select and choose whatever
you want so there's a lot of benefits to
basing the entire ecosystem off of a
couple of core data structures okay but
numpy is old so if you go on to this is
the the syfy git repository this is so
the syfy are older than this is just the
first couple commits inside those
repositories and so this is worked by
Erik Jones you know em thought and
Travis olefins now continuum this were
the first couple commits this is a date
here is relevant right it's 2001 as you
think you know what did you two look
like in 2001 would your palms look like
in 2001 and that was where numpy was
designed right and things have changed
since then so numpy and pandas have some
pretty striking limitations mostly we're
talk about today is they're both single
threaded mostly so they're sort of
designed to use one thread one quarter
of your machine and they are sort of
in-memory data structures okay so
they're not designed to be larger than
what fits comfortably in RAM other other
problems like variable length strings
and poor missing data support which in
2001 no one cared about but today people
care about and so we
Patterson that have come after numpy and
pandas inherit inherit all these
limitations and though that affects us
fairly strongly so hardware has changed
since 2001 we now have many cores we
have nice solid state drives that are
fast with extensions of memory you know
my laptop this laptop is four cores has
four gigabytes of RAM think 100 and get
hundred gigabyte hard drive it's maybe
three years old this is sort of the
machine that i tend to target when I
tend to build libraries old laptop now
they're sort of interesting case is the
sort of 32 or 64 core workstation
feeling fairly interesting this picture
of the Xeon Phi so this is I think you
know some fork or maybe it's an i5 this
is he on Phi we're getting more cores
Moore's Law all my chives problems have
also changed right so numpy was designed
for scientific applications today we
have larger data sets we have messed
your data we have missing values we also
have more text be able to JSON blobs and
log files tend to be a big big pain
point today an umpire python are fairly
terrible at these so there's numpy and
there's pandas and limitations below
them there's Python which is even older
and has more limitations notably so it's
you know sort in 1990 1991 so think
about what your computer looked like in
1991 or even if you were alive in 1991
and you know we didn't have many cores
we didn't have data sets like we have
today and so we had limitations from
Python also notably there's a thing
called the global interpreter lock just
like it has sort of sense the audience
who is her the global interpreter lock
okay I'm getting most people who like
fully Graca global interpreter lock in
these limitations there's a half a hand
over there ok so the Gil it's often
called stops any to python threads from
manipulating python objects at the same
time
so you can still have threads and
they'll sort of trade back and forth as
to who is running but no to Python
threads will actively change Python
objects at the same time and this sort
of destroys Python parallelism it allows
for concurrency but destroys parallelism
and that's a slight difference so that's
that's a pain if you want use multiple
cores in Python right because suddenly
we we can't there are two common
solutions one we give up on threads and
we use processes which are a bit heavier
sort of you have a separate Python
interpreters running the main problem
here is that they can't easily share
data back and forth the other common
solution and one that I think is really
starting to take hold even it's like in
the last week there's been a lot of
progress here is that the Python
ecosystem can just sort of skip the gill
because we spend ninety nine percent of
our time and c and fortran code we
actually don't manipulate python objects
that often you're using sort of pandas
or numpy you should have me putting a
Python object but that Python object
calls out to sea or fortran code and if
you're a little bit careful in designing
numpy and pandas and with other
libraries you can say oh hey wait i'm
going to skip into C or Fortran mode I'm
going to release the gill and then some
other thread can do work while you're
working in C and Fortran mode so we have
the opportunity in PI data not in Python
though Django is sort of screwed but in
PI data we have the opportunity to skip
this problem and there's sort of some
interesting work happening not by me by
other people happening right now so
that's sort of i think an interesting
point the gill doesn't have to affect us
and we'll talk more about how that's
useful a bit
okay so we have the problem that PI data
rests on single threaded foundations
both python and numpy and pandas and
that's fine we've been very productive
on top of those foundations right we've
put hundreds of PhD theses into these
boxes up top and there's just amazing
domain expertise here so the color
scheme here projects that are the sort
of reddish orange color hold the gill so
Python for example holds the gill so it
is hard to paralyze projects that are
sore this light blue color release the
gill and so it is possible to write
parallel code on top of them so they're
not parallel themselves but it's
possible to write parallel code and so
see in Fortran are possible to write
parallel code numpy itself does release
the gill so you can use numpy and many
threads and it can be parallel you can
use you know eight hundred percent CPU
resources it's very nice so if you're
using numpy and multiprocessing wait you
don't have to you can use threading it's
much faster and a sort of above numpy
there's a few projects and some of their
blue some of them are red so notably you
know scikit-learn does release the gill
pandas currently does not and so it's
interesting to sort of look at the map
of all the projects out there and see
which of them you could write parallel
code on top of and which of them you
could not and there's no other things
Fianna was sort of special here because
it is itself parallel so the dark blue
ones how are parallel so they're not not
only can you write / let go to the top
of them but they themselves right
parallel code so Theano user GPUs but it
itself does not release the Gil so if I
want to use the end of multiple times I
have to use prophecies so they're sort
of it's a little bit a little bit weird
so the question really have here is hey
we now have harder problems we now have
more cores we would like to use all of
those cores but maintain all of the
domain expertise and all those PhD
theses that are in the higher projects
so is it possible right can we paralyze
the ecosystem without touching all of
the projects can be a sort of flip a
switch and suddenly have all of these
projects be parallel because something
underneath it is parallel
the answer is probably not that's
probably not going to happen but it
might not be hard so we do need to touch
every project I think there's some
things we need to do but it might not be
hard to paralyze them and sort of look I
do and other people around me also do is
trying to do that and we've tackled
harder things the PI data community is
very strong for example I think most
projects on this slide support both
Python 2 and Python 3 simultaneously and
that's unheard of in the Python
ecosystem right the core or the the web
teams don't effectively do that so we
have a very strong community we have the
ability to make some changes the change
didn't talk about are releasing the gill
also like there's a pull request right
now in pandas where Jeffrey Bach is
slowly releasing the Gil so I kadena JH
released the gill last week so some
interesting things happening almost
release the girl we then talked about
parallel algorithms yes question the
question is can i is there some way to
tell if a library releases the kill one
thing you could do is you could try to
run two functions in that library in
different threads and see if your CPU
resources can go about one hundred
percent if not then it probably doesn't
release the girl you can also ask I
highly recommend that everyone ask every
project truly signal that would be great
I've been applying pressure recently to
projects and it's been sort of if
there's actually they're really
responsive about it but there does need
some pressure from the community okay so
part of my work has been to paralyze not
numpy by something that looks like numpy
so this library called ask array and so
this part of the talk will be sort of a
general talk about a library that I
think you should use or that i would
like feedback on so if you care about
large multi-core raise this is maybe a
sales pitch for library if you don't
care about large multi-core arrays this
is an example of the kind of work that
needs to be done to paralyze things so
where we have a library that is already
releasing the gill now we want to write
parallel code on top of that and so this
sort of an example again of how to
things just to give like a real world
example of how you might paralyze a
process imagine that you're doing your
laundry and you're folding all of your
clothes and suddenly ten friends show up
you say oh great it's going to be 10
times faster but actually that's
actually quite hard because you know
everyone's reaching into the bag at the
same time they all have a different pile
of clothes that they folded it sort of
very hard to paralyze this problem you
need to maybe separate all the socks and
all the shirts in all the pants and then
give one to each friend and so there's
this extra administration that needs to
happen with parallelism sort of a recipe
to follow before you can effectively use
all of your friends to help you
paralyzed some process so you have the
same problem with numpy operations so
the sort of summary here is that desk
array is an out of core when I say out
of core I mean that it works on data
sets that are large in the memory by
effectively using your hard drive it's a
multi it's multi-core and uses all of
your quarters n dimensional array
library in a particular it copies the
numpy interface for a subset of numpy so
it looks and feels very much like numpy
but it works on larger data sets
effectively it does that using blocked
algorithms and we'll talk about what
that means in a second and task
scheduling I'll talk about what that
means to ok there's related work there's
in high performance computing there's
big arrays the sends to be more about
linear algebra in sort of data computing
there's things like who do can spark
which time to sort of aim bigger than
Tasker risk is aiming we're not trying
to replace a duper spark those task
scheduling frameworks like Luigi and
then there's some actually some closer
peers like dist array men thought
Spartan I think it you know York
University and biggest at UK Met Office
if you care about previous work you
should look at those are all great
projects if you don't distinguishing
features of tasker right well we're
focusing on sort of n dimensional array
support as linear algebra we're focusing
on shared memory parallel ism so one
machine not a cluster but just how we
effectively use one machine
it's immediately usable it's pip
installable or Conda installable if you
have any Conda is probably on your
computer right now actually without you
asking for it it also non array things
in there I'll talk at you later ok so we
talk about blocked algorithms in task
scheduling and then a PI interface so
let's break open terminal here so we
have numpy and ask a ring and you'll
numpy a two people if you use numpy here
i'm going to assume or panda this right
the same ish thing so there's numpy and
here's desk array and there's sort of a
similar set of functions in there
doesn't copy everything but a lot of
things are there things like transpose
and tensor dot and tangent mean and some
at all that so we can make some array
you know so let's make an array of
normal random variables with me in 10 in
standard deviation point 10 yeah thank
you huh so let's yeah so
so this would work in numpy except it's
sort of a larger a numpy could handle
this though and we have to add one more
keyword argument here which is chunks so
this is a 10,000 x 10000 array of normal
render variables we're going to cut it
up into a 10 by 10 grid each size
thousand by thousand so each of those
chunks fit very comfortably a memory
even if the whole array does not and we
can do you know the standard things you
lot 100 and then take the mean assets
equals 0 that's an array and we're going
to call compute on that so if you're
familiar with numpy that syntax should
look very familiar to you oh sure ah the
podium I see yeah I'm not going to try
to move that yeah perfect so ed here is
that if you're sort of familiar with
this line of syntax should look very
familiar to refuse dump I I'm just you
know what expensive thing a hard thing
in a small amount of space and only used
a few megabytes of RAM yeah so that's
what i mean by if i own i say that it
sort of copies a numpy interface ok so
we did that with blocked algorithms and
we saw a little bit of that when we
might've talked about chunks we have a
big array that we've sort of parceled
out into many small any small numpy
raise so you think of some some sort
operations you might might do like let's
find the sum of of a trillion element
array so they gave you about trillion
number a with a trillion numbers in it
and some hdf5 fell somewhere so that's
an eight terabyte data set and ask you
to sum all of them how could you do that
so one mechanism is you pull out a
million million sized chunks so pull the
first million numbers take their sum
store that take the second million
numbers take their sum store that do
that 1 million times
I have a million small sums and you do
one more operation which is this final
sum over all of them so I'll Sony made
by a blocked algorithm we're using numpy
in memory but it's on smaller blocks and
an operation like some on the whole task
array is just a million-in-one smaller
sums okay this can get more complex like
if you want to define the meaning of all
of the positive elements you can't quite
just take the mean of all the means
because they might be different sizes so
you take both the sum of all the chunks
and the lengths of all the chunks add up
all the sums out of all the lengths then
divide and so these operations are
sometimes very simple like some and
there's some times more complex like the
mean of the positive elements or you can
think of most people have seen blocked
algorithms when they think about Dickens
are the linear algebra course block
matrix multiply so the most efficient
way to multiply two matrices is to take
them in different chunks and do small
majors multiplies and the same algorithm
for doing matrix multiply it looks
exactly the same as for the blocked
version so ask array does not just sums
but many other things that are sort of
more complex so this for loop is a
problem because Python the language is
going to do one step at a time do the
first chunk of the second trunk but
actually we could do these in any order
and we can do them also simultaneously
so this for loop isn't the right way to
write this we need to describe our
computations and some other way so dasa
can destroy those computations in this
graph and here's my use my favorite part
of the talk actually know where we so I
guess we should put
I'm going to make a desk ray so let me
go brave ones it's give me this very
small array so it's 15 ones and we're
going to put that into blocks of size 5
and we're going to just visualize that
looks like I'm going to start seeing
these graphs so these graphs every
circle it's going to be a function and
every block is going to be an umpire ray
and so our whole array this array of 15
ones is composed of three small numpy
raised each of size five that were each
produced by calling the functions ones
okay this will make more sense in a
second so if I start to build up if I do
operations on my desk array my graph
becomes more complex so here I make much
ones I add one to each of those blocks I
might then you know take the sum of the
whole array is this visible
on the sides okay sort of visible I'm
going to go for that control our control
L I'm this is if it doesn't work it's
their fault yeah I'm not so happy with
that oh you mean just to get more space
or okay yeah let's just put this up here
I leave it easier reading okay so we
write numpy things and we get these
graphs out and I'm going to switch to a
more complex array here slightly more
complex so we get more complex graphs
and this is really nice because you get
to see how these nut by operations turn
into blocked parallel algorithms and so
you can sort of watch the expression I
type here on the right like X plus 1 dot
some and see the kind of operation it
creates on the left so when I did some
we computed a sum of each of the chunks
took all those thumbs together in did a
final sum to get the result so that's
sort of what of what a reduction looks
like making a two-dimensional array and
we can do you know X plus 1 so this
array is a 25 by 25 array cut up into
five by five blocks sorry a 15 by 15 ray
gun / 5 lakhs so there's three times
three there's nine different chunks and
if we you know do these sums we see
things like before and if we do sort of
more complex array operations that array
start to break out in different ways so
we can through like what would X plus X
dot transpose look like think in your
head what that's going to look like and
so here's here's that looks like
this neat you can see what different
operations you know so here is for
example I think you know a node like
these three or on the diagonal because
it's one block talking to itself you
know these nodes require crosstalk and
so they're the blokes blocks off the
diagonal you can think about doing the
matrix multiply yeah just just wait and
we can just keep going with this right
the really nice thing about the numpy
abstraction is that we can keep creating
these graphs completely you know for as
long as we like okay and so sorry I
should also say we create as we do these
numpy sort of a subset of numpy
operations we can keep going ad nauseam
there are things that this can't do
there's no sort operation and desperate
because parallel sorts very hard so
they're definitely limitations right
this is not all of them pie this is a
subset surprisingly large subset that
works quite quite nicely so once you
have that result you call compute and
you get an answer out you know the input
was a lot of one so the answer isn't
very exciting but when I called compute
for threads walk through this graph
executing all of these nodes in a way
that was consistent with the graph right
so we couldn't call this function before
we had that data and they did it in such
a way that if a graph was relatively
large it would respect memory as much as
possible saurian question yeah so the
question is can you then try to ask
right into an umpire ray the answer is
absolutely at that point your whole
array will be sort of brought into
memory so make sure that you do that
after you do some other operations but
yes so tasker a works task array
supports the Thunder array protocol and
so it works anywhere that numpy rays are
sort of expected so i'll show an example
in a second where we throw at a stray
into matplotlib functions and that polyp
just works because it respects these
protocols
yeah yeah okay so let's switch back can
I ask someone to give me some water my
throat's trying out it's not gonna last
there 25 minutes I've ran out of my
water some wonderful person back there I
would appreciate that ok so these graphs
that we've just shown we didn't specify
how they were going to be executed we
just made this sort of recipe but once
we have this recipe we can we can
execute it we can run it with multiple
cores thank you Phillip that was amazing
so sort of show this so we've seen these
graphs before where the circles are
functions the blocks are numpy arrays
and the flow sort of goes up this is
some embarrassing I parallel operation
like x + 1 x to the power of 3 and so
now we've added colors and this is a
trace of the scheduler running blue
things are sort of free or released so
blue circles are done computing and blue
blocks blue numpy raise we've seen them
we've used them we no longer need them
and we've released them from memory
we're being very very careful about the
memory that memory that we use red
things are occupying resources so the
red circles are occupying a thread
they're currently computing and the red
blocks are our in memory their resident
in memory they're filling up our space
and when you notice here is the flow is
going up right so we could have done is
we could have run all of the bottom row
of functions and had a bottom row of
numpy raise all red that would have been
bad that would have filled up memory
instead we have sort of relatively cheap
policies that ensure to accept possible
that that we keep sort of only four red
blocks at a time as little memory as we
we can possibly hold so the schedulers
inside of tasks are very very careful
about managing resources another sort of
point I want to really hammer home here
is that we had this graph and we just
saw that graph being made in lots of
crazy ways and that was separate from
the computation of that graph that was a
separate choice okay so you could make
your own function that executed these
graphs and you could still plug into all
the task array machinery the creation of
those graphs
okay so here's a fail case I think this
is X dot product with X transpose minus
X don't mean alright it's two arrays
there's a fail case here at some point
this whole array this whole row will be
red that's fine that means we need to
spill the disk which we do effectively
but that does slow things down you get
to sort of the hundred megabyte yours
are limited by your disk bandwidth
hundred agra bytes per second something
like that okay so so here's an example
um so dass Garre I need use cases for
desk array so I asked all of my friends
a good friend was Stefan Hoyer who works
on x-ray and worse climate corporation
and he's helping with some you know
sorry we've helped each other build a
nice sort of meteorological data problem
set here is a year of weather data so
this is the temperature two meters from
the ground everywhere on Earth calculate
were calculated every quarter degree of
resolution so I've recorded a real
attitude every quarter degree of
longitude measured every six hours these
tend to be stored in netcdf files which
lot like hdf5 files just sort of a
raised on disk so we look at one of
these and we see that it has the shape
for seven hundred fourteen hundred so
that's you know for time measurements
720 is latitude 1400 is longitude 180
times for 360 times for we have a bunch
of those so we're going to pull those
into all this comprehension so this is
just netcdf datasets the sort of dislike
pointers to file to data on disk they're
not actually loading the data up to all
these aren't pointers we're going to
wrap each of those things with as a task
array and as we do that we tailed ask
array how to how to pull how to grab
data from that thing on disk and a
square works with anything that supports
the numpy get item syntax numpy slicing
and most things like HD h 5 pi or pie
tables or b calls or netcdf all support
that syntax and then weird now we're
just great in numpy land we call
concatenate we get a large array and we
compute the mean and throw it into map
lot lip
this is the average temperature on the
earth for 2014 this data set i think is
like four gigabytes or five gigabytes on
disk in memory it's a bit bigger it took
a couple hundred megabytes to and run on
four course to do this seven Hoyer has
data sets that are much bigger 50
gigabyte of data sets that he plays with
on his laptop which is very fun and it
sort of the question before was you know
can I make this into a numpy array and
note sometimes you actually don't even
have to write because because projects
like matplotlib will do that for you if
you don't they don't receive an umpire
way they'll try to turn in turn umpire
ray and ask supports all the protocols
to make that easy that question right so
the question is are you pulling all the
data from disk into desk arrays and then
computing on them or is it something
else and it's something else so that we
don't pull all the data in at once the
bottom nodes of that graph are pull this
section of this particular netcdf file
into memory then do some computation and
then release and then another node is K
pull this particular other chunk from
this other file into memory and so I
chose note that task array doesn't have
an internal representation there is no
internal memory data structure of a task
array it's just this graph that pulls
data from various places and has numpy
raised in memory so at no point is the
entire array ever resident in memory
it's just sort of a recipe that will
eventually materialize into thing you
wanted so so we can do this on a
terabyte data set if I had the disk
space interestingly I'm more limited by
disk space now than Ram that's actually
what I care about far more these days
fast disk was there a question in the
back
yeah so the question is are we are we
keeping track of intermediate results or
or do we compute things as you'll notice
this is a directed acyclic graph and not
a tree and what do I mean by that I mean
that some of these values like this
value here has many functions that
depend on that value and if you watch
once this goes red it will not turn blue
again until all of these have turned
blue so it's red now and then now it's
blue and so we are keeping track of
intermediate results and we don't
release data until it's it's safe to do
so does that answer your question ah so
if I understand your question correctly
hey I've computed this once now I do
something slightly different do I need
to recompute everything again so that
would be great I have sort of a so one
of the things I do now is I build
interesting schedulers that execute
these graphs with different
computational problems properties and
that would be interesting to do this
sort of staging over time you need to
start of thinking about caching rules so
no there's not kind of thing that does
that well you can compute multiple
arrays simultaneously it could be the
standard deviation and the sum at the
same time the sum comes for free because
a lot of intermediate pieces are cheap
but now that would be a very interesting
thing to work on yeah okay one more
question
yeah so the question is in cases like
this where we have maybe long linear
chains and computations do we need to
have these intermediate results or can
you just fuse all those together the
answers that we fuse so there's a some
part of task is to a certain extent a
compiler that optimizes things okay I
thought I had okay yeah well I'm gonna
skip all questions okay so we've just
seen a desk or a turns numpy code into
these graphs and execute them but we can
also think about not just to raise
there's things like like bags or general
lists of Python objects just seems like
data frames jewel so the custom code
that you have you don't need to think
about about these are the big
collections you might just be a bright
your own graph let's get these get those
quick note data frame is not ready for
public use people get very excited never
mentioned data frame not for putt not
ready yet it does you know nice things
for the politics that I work on it but
it just it's not um not robust enough so
we have these collections things like
desk array but there's more they make
these graphs and then their schedulers
then the nice robust schedulers are all
for single machine parallelism I have a
you know experimental distributed memory
scheduler which could actually those
graphs or do machine but that's also not
quite ready but we don't these two sides
don't need to know about each other
right so you could make your own
collection and make a task that makes
task grass just Python functions that
make these graphs and execute them so i
think that there's a lot of this is a an
avenue like to explore the near future
of forget the collections entirely and
just think about desk graphs and the
task scheduler is as being nice
mechanisms to paralyze other libraries
so what is it asked graph so a doubt
this is the simplest mechanism i could
find to define a dash graph or a graph
of a directed acyclic graph of task
dependencies a dash graph is just a
dictionary
where tasks are tuples the first element
of which is a Python function and the
rest are either data or other keys in
the dictionary so what does that mean
consider this computation or have the
two functions just normal Python
functions increment an ad I set X 21 I
set Y to the result of ink called on X I
set Z to the live ad called the y and 10
ok so it's a very simple computation and
asked you would represent that as this
dictionary ok so i did this sort of
weird thing where can people see this
far down is that no thank you for saying
no ok so that's as good as i can get and
I apologize this is a dictionary done
this weird thing where a function call
is delayed by moving the parentheses
from the right side we don't want we
don't want to call it yet we want to
store as a data structure over the left
Lisp developers will be very happy with
this everyone else thing is kind of
weird well that's a--that's a--that's--
the internal representation of a desk
graph and so if you can make that
dictionary you can use any attack
schedulers you're so don't even need to
import task at this stage so here's
example using array so we saw this
example before with numpy race or the
task arrays and a task array has ADD ask
attribute which is just this dictionary
so if i call a range just make the
number of 0 to 15 dasta splits it up is
three separate calls to the numpy a
range function as we do more complex
things that a dictionary becomes larger
you can imagine having your own you know
pipeline with your own functions in
there and making your own graphs and
then calling I'm not going to resize it
but there's a very simple interface to
call the schedulers on that
okay so you can use the scheduler's
without me to raise is going to last bit
so psychedelic as of a week ago now
depends on desk array they're actually
their second dependency after numpy
we're very very proud and there's a
version of interesting story that
happened so we have a mechanism to
paralyze slightly overlapping regions
which works very well as I could image
functions which need to sort of think
about very local operations you know
windowed operations so Blake Griffith a
task developer whose works continued in
sort of part time work sort of
integrated the two we found it wasn't
very fast because I cadavid didn't
release the gill Johannes Schoenberger
and stephan van der vault released the
gill and asked array or in psych edema
JH oops that's not what I wanted I
wanted that and this pull request is
actually really sick slick this is what
it costs to release the gill you need to
think a little bit about your code but
it mostly means adding no Gil tags and
like no end no Gil with blocks this is
not hard to do and some tests the what
the longest thing is the tests and they
also thought a lot about where it was
safe to do this and now you can use them
together to get sort of two or three XP
dumps that was cheaper okay Jeffrey
block this morning said so Jeffrey Bach
is now slowly releasing the gill and
pandas okay that's it thank you all for
your time probably don't have time for
questions but please tops
thank you very much Matthew I was a
great talk we maybe do have time for one
last quick question word the big
achievement of numpy was to unify
community so to have 11 array
representation and now you have bigger
sense port on and dusk so do I guys talk
to each other or we again in this stage
where we split community a little bit
and this sense yeah that's a great
question I have so we all talk to each
other socially I think we've talked
seriously about the different projects I
would say so disparate you also forgot
there's also a good project I don't know
the development status of Spartan I
think the main developer sort of left
and a couple people now working on it is
mostly academic I reached out to them
haven't gone much back I haven't talked
to the disarray people recently but
there's big overlap Blake Griffith
actually notably used to work on that
dist array and I'm talking to the
biggest guys next week I'm going to I'm
usually in California I mean you know
your app for a bit so I'm going to go
talk to them there's not as much
conversation is I would like to have but
it's also okay it's an experimental
field I'd also suggest that there's also
a lot of excellent task scheduling
frameworks that there's also a sort of
open opportunity for more conversation
that also isn't happening so you talked
about arrays but also task scheduling is
a big open big open space all of us also
support the numpy the array protocol I
think is ok to have disparate projects
as long as you adhere to some protocols
and numpy did do a good job at
standardizing that so they maybe now is
a good time for a fermentation yeah ok
thank you
you
you